and all I had to do was not reveal my
evil plan why do we villains always do
that why do we have this strange need to
tell you all of our most devious plots
before we do them I mean that always
gives you that last minutes aim that
last minute effort that gets you through
all perhaps we reveal some flaw in our
plan that you're able to exploit but not
this time
this time I kill fast and I groped later
this is so much better
no I get to brag and bragging is so much
better than revealing my part now it's
time for my victory dance dad hmm
staring over your lifeless body now I'm
wondering what am I gonna do next
cuz now I'm just bored maybe I should
see what's on Netflix